何度コメント欄で言われたことか
シルクとはじめんでバスケして下さいって
メッチャめちゃ言われましたね
めっちゃ言われるよね？
見てもらって解ると思うんですけど、
ポジションが違うんですよ
ガードでしょ？
真逆
僕ガードですね
結構センター寄りなんで
ポジョションが違うから、役目も違うから
役目違うし、何だったら生かし生かさるの関係ですもんね
なのでここで一対一をしても
なんか、こう違うんですよね
そうですね
係りかたが
今日は２対２にします！
これで丁度、
バランスがー
バランス良いなー
こういう　にはポジシション的には
そうです。確かに
ンダホとおいら被って、シルクとたくみが多分、
そですね、同じくらい
これでちょうど別れれば、多分ポジション的にはいい感じに
ガード、センター。
これでいい勝負が出来るんじゃないか？
そんな肩使わなくたって・・・
では早速、シルク対はじめ戦って来ます！て・・・
さあ、いよいよ始まりました
はじめんず、VSシルク率いるサラコーンズ
すなわちフィッシャーズ
さあ、結果はどうなるか先ずは
ジャンケンで先攻後攻を決めます
ここは、先攻がはじめんずの様ですね
はい、先攻はじめんずでございます。
はじめんず、事前調査によりますと、
最近した運動は
アスレチック集団のフィッシャーズに
どこまで戦えるかが見どころですね
先ずは、ドリブルで攻めていく
お互い先ずは手探りから始まるか
パスが出る！
通った！
シュート！
かすりもしない！
先ずは良い、
取りあえずシュートで終わろうという作戦でしょうか
シルクのボールを持つ。たくみがディフェンスを突く
ンダホ、肉体が揺れる
ドリブル！
パス！
さぁ、はじめんずボール、たくみキャッチをミスる
ボールを渡す、
ドリブル、ローリングしてからの
ロングシュート
入るか！
入ったー
先ずは、はじめんず一点先取　取りました
が、ここからです、
ディフェンス
ここで上手く、守りたい所ではあります
ンダホ選手うまいこと場所を取りつつ動く
シルクがボールを突く
ここで上手いこと道ができれば
おっと！入るか
シュート
離れてからのシュート、外れる
ンダホ、ボールを取る
あぁ！ンダホ、パスを出す、おっと高いか？
出ないが、ｷﾞﾘ、ボールを持つ。
ドリブルで、シュート！
入るか
入ったー
２対２です。まだ勝負はここからの様です
先ずはパスを出す
たくみ選手戻す
ドリブルで攻め寄る
後ろ！
おっと、通らない、ギリ危ないか
さ、フィッシャーズボール、ンダホにボールを出そうとしていますが
なかなか・・・
低くドリブル
ここから打てるか？
さあ、はじめんずボールです。
正直やっていた側としてはここでもう
体力の限界を感じていました
パス！  通るか？
ヘッド！ヘッド！ヘッドーーー
頭で返そうと思ったがこれはミスか、ンダホ転ぶ！
こんな事があっていいのだろうか？
さあ、フィッシャーズボール
大きなミスを犯してしまいましたが、まだ点数は２対２
ここからです、うまいことンダホにボールを回さずにいます
ちょっと攻めずらそう・・・か？
さ、はじめんずボールここで点数を押えておきたい
パス！
シュート！なんでシュートだ！
ゴールにかすりもしないよ！
フィッシャーズボール、ドリブルで攻めていく
かわす、
抜かれたー！
シュートと思ったらンダホにパス、
ンダホにボールが通る
ンダホ戻す
ここからどう攻めるか
ここは丁寧に決める
フィッシャーズ逆転です
これはどうする、はじめんずボール
さ、ここでンダホが抜けるか、抜いた！
ノールック放り投げバックシュート
なんてシュートだ!!
皆さんに先に言っておきましょう
たくみ選手、これは悪気がある訳ではありません
リバウンド、シルク選手が取る
ンダホ場所を取るがなかなかパスが回らない
ンダホにパスが回った
胸張りはじめん、態度だけはデカい
つい２週間前まで会社員だった彼はもうこんなにフラフラ
先ずは、はじめんず一点先取　取りました
ディフェンス
ここで上手く、守りたい所ではあります
ンダホ選手うまいこと場所を取りつつ動く
シルクがボールを突く
ここで上手いこと道ができれば
おっと！入るか
シュート
離れてからのシュート、外れる
ンダホ、ボールを取る
あぁ！ンダホ、パスを出す、おっと高いか？
出ないが、ｷﾞﾘ、ボールを持つ。
ドリブルで、シュート！
入るか？
入ったー！
後ろ！
おっと、通らない、ギリ危ないか